I don't ever disregard the fact that
however hard to work you know it doesn't
always guarantee it's gonna happen I
will never ever base my career and
success or number ones or awards it's
about being happy my mom is dad would
never let me put posters on the wall
because I like being here be inspired
but don't become anyone happens she's an
English singer-songwriter recognized for
her unconventional musical style she's
the first British female artist to have
six top-ten singles from a single studio
album she sold over 20 million singles
and 3 million albums worldwide
she's Jessie J and here's my take on her
top ten rule to the set remember - is my
personal favorite and I'm curious if
your girl which one you guys like the
best and as always guys if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it as well so other
people can be inspired also when you
write it down you're much more likely to
lock it into yourself as well enjoy
I don't ever disregard the fact that
however hard you work you know it
doesn't always guarantee it's gonna
happen and that's the thing that you
have to just believe if you don't
believe in you no one else will even
bother to look at you and I shoved
myself around any open mics any Sikhs
any type the amount of stuff I've
probably done even up to now 8090
percent of my gigs for free the round of
services that you can trust surrounded
other people about letting be huge
don't ever comes like compromise but
don't ever you know lose what makes you
you
right from the heart stay happy and
always remember there's always someone
worth less removed and is always someone
is working rather than in as well when
you're asleep there someone grasping and
that's what ethnic number as well that
for every 10 CDs you send off if someone
sending over 400 just get yourself out
there if you can and film everything one
thing I've learned that I'm glad that I
did footage from years ago that looking
the place below you you copy so so
you've done it you've done that I'm like
going into this body's going through the
same songs are the same hair stuff it's
just people as fun as well write it down
make the write down hit pictures and
make sure it's a journey and the journey
is way more important than where you
enter England up especially Monday if
you want to be a fireman go and do it
you want to be a ballet dancer than go
and be a ballet dancer today I believe
in yourself and no one else will believe
in you and then yes it's an important
it's so important for me to people to
understand that I want to be an
inspiration I was really and kind of
nine out of ten children are and I want
it I want to be a role model I think now
I'm in the kind of lie months ago it's
okay
and it's especially what I believe like
ones that have something most cool and
it's something that you can turn into a
positive and not let it lead you away
and then always be someone that says you
can't do it they'll always see someone
that says I don't believe in you
there'll always be someone that says I
do believe in you there's always some
that says you can do it
and that's security has to focus on how
much energy trying to put me down which
they do when they say you know every
time I need your file and I burn my ears
I say she's laughing that I will never
surround myself with people that tell me
on perfect because not and I don't want
to be I'm 23 sometimes I sing out too
and sometimes Eileen is waiting and on a
game way sometimes the safe soft I
shouldn't and sometimes I'm going to
make the same spot life would be boring
if you lived it like it's going to be
really in the paper and their bodies so
I figured it was out to me was pitchy
I've never mind and I'm proud of that I
like to read reviews I don't take them
in as facts because one person's opinion
isn't you know the epitome of life it's
not the defending of my of my work but
I'm very very interested to see what
people think because they baby melodious
things that I may not have noticed you
know I've listened to this album you
know 70 times in the last month so I'm
not hearing things that people other
people may notice you know so that's
always important for me to always try
and better myself but listen to the
right people I have my dream list and
I've checked a few things off and I add
things on every day I think laughs about
dreaming big and I think I've realized
if you put your mind to it and you kind
of a lot of people I think seem to think
I've popped out of nowhere and I've been
assigned for seven years and there's
been a lot of times I was like this
isn't going to happen you know and it
gets really tough and who you are songs
like that made me carry on and I will
never ever base my career and success or
number ones or awards it's about being
happy and I just need to make sure that
I'm happy which I am so we're all good
in the hood
okay if you're if you're a teacher of
school and there's 30 teachers in the
ossicles the teachers room so cool start
our own mirror at the staff room and
there's one teacher that hates you
that's going to play
any normal person wouldn't just be able
to go all these who were like me but is
that one person has given me evils
that's not giving me a biscuit you know
that it is not a normal human thing to
want to be liked by people that you
don't know why they don't like here but
I've realized that I can't keep
everybody happy and that if everyone was
the same then everyone won't agree with
the way I live my life but they're not
and that's something you have to accept
and they're successful so they should
just enjoy the people that are support
in them yeah
always yeah everybody deals with
criticism in their own way I just have
to remember that a lot more people have
an opinion but everyone feels the same
like if somebody came up to you in the
street and was like and what you're
wearing I hate you
you wouldn't go Thanks lovely to meet
you your instinct would be lovely
but you have to remember that there's no
point in wasting your energy on that and
one of the reasons I honestly wrote is
my party was almost verbally try and
give those people a hug because the
people that need that criticism all the
time that's constantly pushing the hate
on everyone else the people that need a
hug people won't know what I went
through between the second or third
album of the sphere that was implemented
in me even though I knew I was talented
I have to be confident in what I do
and that song was one of the first songs
that I recorded for the album and I was
actually going to call the album
masterpiece and I just thought no it
doesn't make sense if people hear on its
own it just sounds convenient up the
[ __ ] but for me I I've never made it
I've never finished my painting until
the day that my eyes closed and I don't
wake up I feel like I'm still putting
towards my masterpiece and I want to
work hard and I'm okay to say hey I've
messed up I do things I say things are
working by day people I shouldn't buy
abandonment and they're all building on
something that we hope can leave a
standing of the test of time and I think
that's what that song means to me and I
really really put it towards other
people that have gone you can't do this
or lied about me and said I'm difficult
or this and that and call me a diva and
when I'm not I'm passionate now there's
a very very
when people can't deal with our
passionate you are they attack you and
that's the same within any any anyone
just make sure that you surround
yourself with people that you see in
your future
that were in your past and they're still
making an effort to be in your present
to make sense good advice
it's really important I think don't ever
base your friendship from the past don't
ever think people should just stay in
your life because you went to school
together you everyone changes and you
grow up and just make sure you surround
yourself with people that are making the
effort to love you for who you are today
and who you are tomorrow don't become
like a cult you like don't just like me
be a fan of everyone you can like
Rihanna's music online and Gaga's it's
okay don't have to be like I'm rejected
by Roger you know and my mama's dad
would never let me put posters on the
wall because I like being here be
inspired but don't become anyone elses
which is why I think other nights I
wasn't very very the one thing I was
very proud of as when I first came out I
one compared me to anyone I think you
can tell when someone's idolized
somebody sometimes and I I think it's
good to be inspired but don't become
somebody yeah I mean yourself it's
always be yourself
always whether people say about you
wherever people believe that is true
that isn't about you trust me
life is not worth living feeling sad and
down and lonely it's always be true to
who you are I like to give myself
heatstroke and make myself look like a
complete donor in public I so for good
cause everyone saw that cameras out
oh yeah all right let's do it
hello okay so this is I can't even see
this is Mike really good in my gorilla
outfit and I'm just doing a song that I
wrote called stand up pretty if you
surrender so from negative people will
never feel so good and I become an equal
molar that's a perk you obviously
recurring if you don't know the way
stick underneath No
okay yeah comparable well it another
Hanna lifestyle not known but in the
moment in my career but a lot Louisville
area
Oh
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Shahrukh a asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down accounts below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what a Jessie J
say that has the biggest impact on you
what lesson are you going to take from
this video and immediately apply it to
your life or business somehow leave it
down the comments below and I'm going to
join in the discussion finally I want to
give a quick shout out to Charlie farm
Charlie thank you so much for picking up
one of my t-shirts actually two of my
t-shirts and posting that picture on
Twitter I hope you're enjoying the shirt
you look great on you and thank you
again for your order so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
price tag more about remember that when
you don't have money you don't need to
go to a fire fast five-star hotel and in
our and being a jean paul gaultier dress
in order to kind of stand amazing just
have a little picnic in your front room
you know and just remember that your
models your beliefs and the people
around you are more important sometimes
than how much money is going to pocket
so there was a time when you were like I
don't know if there's ever going to
happen yeah I feel like everything every
time I took a step forward like my foot
broke or this happened or that I had a
stroke when I was 18 just as I got fined
and like it's always kind of it's been
moments I'm like ah but nothing that's
ever kind of stopped me but I felt like
obviously my second album didn't get
released in the US and that was a big
knock back for me because it just didn't
feel right here which is fair and it
wasn't my choice but again it's
frustrating because you want all the
fans to grow with you even if it's not
what you feel they might love but I just
felt like where I'm at right now I'm
very appreciative like even what
happened today like I never ever thought
I would see my name at the top of the
iTunes chart in the US ever like so I'm
feeling pretty strong as often now I'm
just now I'm just I feel really like
like 1% of artists get to release a
third album you know like only one
person can sit at the top like for that
moment and so when you have it you just
have to enjoy it we'll have to
appreciate it